[Musique]
bien que d'autres arrivent dans l'épisode spécial d'aujourd'hui sur la
clandestinité, mais
passons d'abord directement à l'invité d'aujourd'hui,
le 8e secrétaire général des Nations
Unies, Ban ki-moon, qui était
secrétaire général pendant l'
épidémie de M Allah de 2013 à 2016, il  me rejoint via
Skype depuis Séoul merci beaucoup d'être
venu plaisanter avant d'arriver dans le
reste du monde comment gérez-vous personnellement
la quarantaine et quels
conseils donneriez-vous au centre pour
les citoyens du monde que vous auriez quels conseils
donneriez-vous  aux gens qui regardent partout
dans le monde aujourd'hui, la communauté mondiale est aux
prises avec la diffusion du roman copie
19, il est très opportun que nous réfléchissions à
l'importance de notre propre santé, de la santé de notre
famille et de la santé de nos
communautés et du monde maintenant, même
si je suis  hors de mon entreprise en tant
qu'ancien en tant que deuxième général, mais j'exerce également
de nombreuses fonctions différentes en tant que
vice-président des anciens ainsi
que président du centre pan-allemand pour
la cit mondiale  izens en fait, j'ai
travaillé avec de nombreux leaders mondiaux,
y compris le propre
directeur général de WH, Ted Ted Rose, le top La
nature a joué un rôle de leadership vital
non seulement dans cette crise sanitaire
mondiale, mais dans de nombreuses crises internationales à
travers le monde pendant mon mandat de
secrétaire  Le général Tom Rachel a marché pour
combattre avec les nations unies
telles que h1n1 en 2009 et ebola 2014 dans les
deux cas, les Nations Unies moi-même et
le directeur général ont fait preuve d'
un leadership incroyable de très près pour
les États membres et la communauté mondiale a
aidé à
surmonter aujourd'hui il y a un grand  les
défis de santé publique par la coopération
et la solidarité puis-je juste dire
bien sûr que vous applaudissez qui
pensez-vous qu'ils ont appris beaucoup de leçons
quand vous c'est vous en tant que secrétaire général
qui avez semblé intervenir sur em Allah quand
ça a frappé  Guinée Libéria et Sierra Leone
parce que le WH er n'a pas répondu aussi
bien qu'il aurait pu à ce moment-là à
ce moment-là que nous avions je peux vous dire t  Que nous ayons
eu une meilleure gouvernance, une gouvernance mondiale
, un système qui et maintenant, alors
que tous les pays ont
pris leurs propres initiatives et
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient faire dans leur propre
pays, mais à cette époque, les Nations
Unies ont travaillé en étroite collaboration avec le WH.
un système de gouvernance mondiale,
nous travaillons en étroite collaboration avec la Banque mondiale
et les banques de l'Union européenne et d'autres banques
régionales de la Banque africaine de développement,
l'Union africaine, il y a donc eu une coordination beaucoup plus
étroite à leur égard,
c'est une chose dont je peux vous dire qu'il
nous manque à  cette fois, que ce soit pour
lutter contre le coronavirus ou le changement climatique,
nous devons tous travailler ensemble en partenariat,
un facteur clé apparemment dans le
succès de la Corée du Sud cette fois-ci avec le
coronavirus est qu'il a fait de grosses erreurs
lors de l'épidémie de MERS pensez-vous
que c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles la Corée du Sud a
été si  réussi, il n'y a même pas de
verrouillage en Corée du Sud en ce moment, je
crois que mon pays, la République de
Corée, a fait une remarque  parfaitement bien parce que les
gens et le gouvernement, je pense que nous
avons travaillé très très étroitement, les gens
avaient une confiance totale dans ce que le
gouvernement a fait en premier
lieu,
un test massif pour toutes les
personnes potentielles, la première chose que le gouvernement sud-coréen
a faite quand vous savez ce qu'ils
eu les premiers cas, puis nous avons demandé
aux industries médicales de fabriquer les
plaques de test testant les enfants.
Je pense qu'ils produisent maintenant au
moins une centaine de milliers de
kits de test, même vous vous souvenez peut-être que le
président Trump a demandé de
fournir certains kits de test au  Les États-
Unis et nous avons informé les
gens du gouvernement de
manière très transparente et les tests
ont été effectués au moins plus de
mille personnes par jour à
pied ou en voiture, cela a été
étiqueté comme un isolement précoce pour les personnes
testées positives  réduire le risque de
propagation comme d'autres pays La Corée du
Sud a également développé son propre
logiciel de lutte contre les coronavirus  e et les
applications mobiles pour aider
les efforts de recherche des contacts vraiment centraux, ils ont déployé des efforts de recherche
incroyablement efficaces de
sorte qu'une fois qu'une
personne est testée positive, nous
avons retrouvé toutes les personnes
avec lesquelles cette personne positive a été contactée et
cela a vraiment aidé à  réduire le nombre
de personnes maintenant que nous avons environ 9 000
certains cas, mais le nombre de décès
est de 160 ou certains, donc cela a été
assez efficace, ce
qui signifie que le public a accepté et
fait confiance aux majors que le gouvernement coréen
a pris, on peut supposer que cette
confiance  vient du fait que les
institutions tiennent le public
pleinement informé 24 heures sur 24 et
demandent leur coopération et que le
gouvernement coréen tient également le public informé
des messages de masse sur les numéros quotidiens
et les rappels de distanciation sociale,
etc. Je pense et c'est pourquoi j'ai même
bien que je ne sois pas au service du gouvernement,
j'ai reçu de nombreux déprimés de la
part de mes amis personnels d'Hawaï  un
gouvernement qui traitait avec
certains pays européens pour fournir un
soutien et savoir comment tout contact avec la
Grande-Bretagne parce que, de toute évidence, l'
Organisation mondiale de la santé a déclaré que nous
devons tester le test comme vous venez de le dire, l'
administration Trump a appelé
la réponse de la Grande-Bretagne comme étant  Je pense que
Donald Trump a dit à un moment
catastrophique
que peut faire le patron de WH o Tedra Saddam
doit-il être très diplomate quand
il voit un pays comme la Grande-Bretagne pas de nouveaux
tests en fait à partir de cette semaine il y
avait une limite à 15% sur  test du
personnel de première ligne du NHS ici en Grande-Bretagne Je peux
comprendre et apprécier les
difficultés et parfois pas très
organisé au début de cette
propagation massive du virus koruna Je peux
comprendre toute cette
situation difficile Je n'ai été contacté par aucun
gouvernement britannique mais j'espère  que l'
Union européenne
devrait avoir une manière plus coordonnée
dans le cadre de l'Union européenne maintenant, ce qui me
préoccupe vraiment, c'est que chacun
le gouvernement fait de sa propre
initiative n'a pas
beaucoup coordonné chaque atome bien sûr
et je comprends qu'il était nécessaire
de verrouiller chacun et d'autres pays,
mais parfois cela pourrait également entraver la
coordination coordonnée de la lutte contre ce
virus saisies
bien nous sommes sous verrouillage ici  à Londres,
malgré certains doutes quant à
son efficacité, l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé a également déclaré que la Chine avait
très bien réagi à l'épidémie du
virus corona, mais ici en Grande-Bretagne, nous
entendons des informations du numéro 10 Downing
Street selon lesquelles la Chine fait face à un jugement
après  cette crise des coronavirus et il peut
être considéré comme un État paria sur sa
gestion, pourquoi pensez-vous qu'il semble y
avoir une animosité
géopolitique créée par le coronavirus, en
particulier en provenance de Londres,
évidemment, il sort de Washington
contre le Venezuela en ce moment, je pense
que ce genre  de ressentir des animosités
ou de critiquer certains pays de cette
manière ne sera d'aucune utilité  bien sûr, au
début de cette crise, la Chine et
même mon pays, la Corée, ont été
critiqués par leur propre peuple pour ne pas
avoir été plus un forum et une voie correcte,
mais au fil du temps, la Chine et
le gouvernement sud-coréen ont fait des
progrès  progrès et efficace, en
particulier dans mon pays, il a été
assez efficace et, comme vous le savez peut-être, plus
de 100 pays ont
protégé le gouvernement sud-coréen pour
les informations nécessaires, c'est ce qui
est nécessaire en ce moment, vous
savez que vous avez des connaissances sur le
La Grande-Bretagne est contactée en Corée du Sud, je ne suis pas
sûr parce que je ne fais pas partie du gouvernement,
mais d'après ce que j'ai compris dans les médias,
plus d'une centaine de pays ont
demandé des informations et partagé le
savoir-faire et également plus d'une centaine de
pays ont
demandé à avoir des dispositions  des
enfants des soins de santé, en particulier un test des
enfants et des masques et c'est ce qui est
nécessaire en ce moment, il devrait y avoir
une coordination plus claire et beaucoup plus étroite et  d
soutien entre et parmi les pays
maintenant, le pays unique, aussi puissant
et ingénieux soit-il, comme vous le voyez dans
le cas des États-Unis, je pense que
le nombre de cas ainsi qu'un certain nombre
de décès aux États-Unis en Italie
et en Espagne est assez  ne comprends pas à propos de
cette époque les pays les plus ingénieux les plus
puissants sont même de ne pas avoir de
capacité immédiate en ce moment le
virus ne respecte aucune
ethnie et manière ou pays frontaliers leur
forme est très importante que nous partageons
nous vivons dans un monde
vidéo de communication donc il y aura beaucoup de
façons de partager des expériences et pas de
maison oui quelqu'un a fait remarquer que les
virus ne peuvent pas communiquer entre
eux mais les humains peuvent c'est là que
nous avons l'avantage sur le virus ban
ki-moon je vous arrête  il y a plus de
l'ancien secrétaire général de l'ONU après
cette pause
[Musique]
bon retour je suis toujours ici avec l'ancien
secrétaire général de l'ONU Ban ki-moon vous
ne comprenez pas alors que tant que C  Des
médecins chinois sont arrivés ici en
Grande-Bretagne Des médecins cubains bien sûr en Italie
en Espagne Des avions militaires russes
arrivent à New York Downing Street ici,
il y a des gens en Grande-Bretagne qui disent que la Chine
doit être punie par le retrait des
contrats Internet après la fin de la
crise des coronavirus et les gens  au Royaume-Uni dans
les couloirs du pouvoir suggérant que la
Chine exploite le coronavirus à
des fins économiques, ce que je peux vous dire
en ce moment, c'est que pointer du doigt
n'importe quel autre pays comme la Chine fait cette
aide ne sera pas utile, nous vivons
dans un monde globalisé  chaque seconde je
pense que vous pouvez entendre tout ce qui se
passe dans un pays avec le
développement transformateur de l'
information de communication de transport
je pense que nous vivons dans une petite planète
Terre petit monde
donc ce qui se passe en Chine
Corée pain Grande-Bretagne ou États-Unis
ce n'est pas ça qui devrait  être traités comme
nous vivons dans un petit monde
donc il est en fait nécessaire que
nous devons coopérer pleinement c'est ce que
j'ai vécu en travaillant aux
Nations Unies c'est ce sur quoi j'ai
insisté tout le temps c'est très facile
de blâmer quelqu'un
mais le problème quelqu'un c'est que nous devrions
faire ce que nous pouvons faire en premier et particulièrement en
tant qu'ancien second  général, je suis également préoccupé par le
fait que le langage linguistique n'est pas beaucoup
parlé par de grands pays
comme les Européens et les Américains qui
ne parlent pas de soutien mondial pour
les pays du Sud qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
capacité et de ressources maintenant alors que les
États-Unis ont
réussi à avoir  deux billions de dollars
à ce moment-là, j'espère que cela aurait
dû être une considération pour fournir
le certain fonds mondial pour le Sud, vous
savez ce que les gens du
sud du monde et c'est ce que le
leadership mondial signifie vraiment, vous savez
souvent même le strict minimum pour survivre
il manque ça autour de la
capacité des moyens et si vous voulez arrêter le
virus c'est ce dont beaucoup d'autres pays
auront besoin  d en tant que tel, nous avons besoin d'
une communauté mondiale pour agir de manière solidaire
même en période de grand besoin, nous devons nous
rappeler que nous sommes tous dans le
même bateau et bien la Grande-Bretagne aide sans doute le
sud global en exportant des armes quelle
est l'importance de la Charte des Nations Unies en ce
moment particulier  pas plus tard que cette semaine, l'Arabie
saoudite a bombardé le Yémen, le pays le plus pauvre
du Moyen-Orient face à un virus corona,
une pandémie,
Israël a bombardé la Syrie, à quel point la
Charte des Nations Unies est-elle importante en ce moment particulier,
car elles sont considérées par beaucoup comme des
violations discutables de la Charte des Nations Unies,
vous vous en souvenez peut-être.  le 23 mars, si je
me souviens bien, le secrétaire général
des Nations unies, Antonio Guterres,
a autorisé et fait appel à un
cessez-le-feu mondial, appelez un cessez-le-feu, en particulier
en cette période de difficultés, maintenant
c'est tout simplement insensé qu'ils essaient maintenant
de trouver en particulier dans celui qui se
déroule le  des pays comme le Yémen
Syrie et regardez les tant de millions
de réfugiés que ces pays ont parmi
la plupart des gens  e vivant en eux,
il est donc essentiel que
l'aide humanitaire puisse parvenir aux personnes
qui en ont le plus besoin et qui en ont le plus besoin
et avant tout, ils doivent
cesser de se battre
bien après que le secrétaire général a fait
ces remarques, l'administration Trump
a maintenant ordonné des navires de guerre au  côte du
Venezuela
qu'en est-il des sanctions parce que Donald
Trump a exclu tout allègement des
sanctions ferb dire que l'Iran nous avions le
rapporteur spécial des Nations Unies sur ce programme Idris
jasiri qui a déclaré que les sanctions sont généralement
illégales êtes-vous d'accord avec ce que l'ONU
dit à Genève que l'UE le  Les États-
Unis doivent arrêter les sanctions contre des pays
comme l'Iran Cuba évidemment leurs sanctions
contre la Chine pendant cette pandémie les
pays russes ont averti la sanction
imposée par ceux-ci par le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
comme la Syrie l'Iran la Corée du Nord et le
Venezuela en ce moment alors que nous respectons
les sanctions imposées par le
Conseil de sécurité en même temps, il serait
bon que le Conseil de sécurité examine
si, au cas par cas, ont-ils
pourrait envisager de lever ces sanctions
à des fins humanitaires vous avez dit
que l'un des succès en Corée du Sud
a été l'importance accordée par le
gouvernement à la transparence la transparence
avec le public quelle est l'importance de l'article
19 de la Charte des Nations Unies les autorités britanniques
ici menacent tout le temps  les
chaînes de télévision étrangères pensez-vous que la
transparence de l'article 19 est encore plus
importante pendant cette crise face à
ce type de cas de pandémie mondiale, il
est si important que les gens
soient informés chaque seconde chaque
minute chaque milliseconde de
ce qu'ils doivent faire  et ce que les
gouvernements font donc
chaque citoyen peut prendre sa propre
nature
quelle que soit sa propre projection, mais
ce type de pandémie mondiale devrait être
traité au niveau mondial, l'
information devrait toujours être disponible
à ce niveau, vous savez de quelle manière
transparente, de manière transparente parce que  évidemment, il
prétend ici en Grande-Bretagne la Chine Russie
il y a  les pays créent délibérément de
fausses nouvelles et
c'est un gros problème c'est peut-être un problème plus gros
que la pandémie le New York Times
dit que la Chine diffuse publiquement de la
désinformation eh bien je ne suis pas en
mesure de faire des commentaires sur de telles
questions que je ne suis pas  traiter directement
avec, mais vous savez que les fausses nouvelles, quelles
qu'elles soient, ne sont pas totalement vous savez que cela ne
vous aide à rien,
donc devrait être très clair
et dans la publication immédiate d'
informations correctes afin que les citoyens disent que les
tentatives ont pu prendre les
mesures nécessaires en  leur propre capacité en
même temps dans un sens plus large, ce sont
les dirigeants du gouvernement et de la communauté
et les dirigeants mondiaux qui devraient vraiment
prendre l'initiative de traiter et de combattre
Courbet a-19, évidemment, ce sont les plus
vulnérables qui vont être touchés
par corona  virus vous avez mentionné les réfugiés
nous parlions dans cette émission des porteurs d'
hôpitaux et des nettoyeurs pourquoi
pensez-vous que les plus vulnérables seront
les devraient être  la priorité pendant la
crise du virus corona car les
conditions de vie pour les messages comme vous auriez
pu l'être dans de nombreux camps de réfugiés, ils
vivent dans des zones denses très compactes, vous
savez, nous sommes informés que nous avons conseillé aux
citoyens d'avoir une distance
sociale distance sociale au moins un  ou à deux
mètres les uns des autres, mais
comme vous pouvez aller dans des camps de réfugiés, plusieurs
millions de personnes vivent dans une
zone très compacte sans beaucoup d'installations,
tout d'abord dans des installations d'hygiène et
il est donc beaucoup plus facile beaucoup plus
vulnérable pour elles d'être  contractés par
ces virus, la raison pour laquelle il y a des
réfugiés a souvent été évoquée en
termes de guerres créant la pauvreté
pensez-vous que lorsque tout cela sera terminé, nous
devrons revoir l'égalité et les
politiques comme l'exigence du FMI de
privatiser les systèmes de santé en  retour
pour les prêts dans les régions où maintenant les guerres
ont amené tous ces réfugiés à monter
les chiffres du montage en
termes c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi je suis watc  incitant
les dirigeants mondiaux à créer un
fonds mondial pour les pays du Sud et à accorder plus d'
attention aux personnes les plus
vulnérables, la
Grande-Bretagne est enfin sur le point d'annuler sa prochaine série
de sommets mondiaux sur le climat, le
sommet COPE, que pouvons-nous apprendre du
coronavirus sur  l'importance de dire
le new deal vert évidemment rejeté par
la Maison Blanche mais je comprends que
vous avez fait beaucoup de travail sur la promotion de
l'idée de new deal verts partout dans
le monde qui est clairement une relation très étroite
entre la lutte contre le changement climatique l'
action climatique  en plus de faire
face à cette crise pandémique en
ce moment, je suis préoccupé par le fait qu'en
raison de cette crise pandémique, je
crains que les efforts et la passion
pour faire face à une crise climatique en ce moment
ne soient à l'esprit, peut-être en
baisse par le commerce  les gens du
monde entier ce qui est le plus important en ce
moment et qu'à travers et le
new deal vert européen sont les selon un
changement climatique de paris des femmes nous  doit prendre
des mesures urgentes avant qu'il ne soit trop tard car
vous savez que la température mondiale mondiale se
réchauffe, il y a de plus
en plus de possibilité que ce type de
groupe par contre mandamus puisse se produire car
il peut y avoir une manière indésirable ou un mélange de tous
ces agents pathogènes parmi vous connaissent les animaux
et d'autres conditions naturelles et
il est donc très important en ce
moment de tirer les leçons de cette crise, nous devons
prendre des mesures urgentes pour faire face à la
crise climatique avant qu'il ne soit trop tard, mais les
entreprises de combustibles fossiles qui ont longtemps
douté de l'existence de  changement climatique,
leurs patrons étaient à la maison blanche l'
autre jour,
aucun d'entre eux ne dit qu'il existe la moindre
preuve que le changement climatique
contribue aux pandémies, je suis vraiment d'
origine car l'Union européenne a
annoncé que ce Green Deal européen
d'au plus tard  2050 toutes ces quatre
structures devraient être vous savez la transe
transformée en énergie
renouvelable énergie renouvelable interroger j'ai visité de
nombreux pays européens nous  ont déjà
annoncé que d'ici 2035 2040 ou d'ici 2050, la
plupart des pays européens de l'
Union euro, à l'exception de la Pologne, se sont
engagés à être un continent sans combustibles fossiles d'
ici là. J'exhorte également
de nombreux pays autres que les
pays européens à faire cet effort
que  J'exhorte également le gouvernement des
États-Unis
à revenir sur ce changement climatique des
femmes dès que possible, c'est leur
responsabilité politique et morale en tant
que pays ingénieux et puissant le plus important, comme vous vous en souvenez peut-
être, c'était les États-Unis et la Chine, vous
savez.  travailler avec les États-
Unis et d'autres nations élues avec d'
autres États membres pour vraiment mener à bien ce
changement climatique des femmes,
maintenant que cela fait déjà 50
ans que l'ajout de l'
accord sur le changement climatique et
des objectifs de développement durable est dans certains
bonnes leçons que nous devons tirer de
cette crise pandémique que nous devons
déployer beaucoup beaucoup plus d'efforts  sur un moyen beaucoup
plus rapide de faire face à la crise climatique
[Musique]